hey guys welcome back last episode was
awesome we got an executor in the end
which I'm still psyched about amazing
Pokemon and this time around we have
quite a few evolution saved up I did
catch a growlithe so we're gonna get
that long-awaited arcanine finally also
ninetails nidoking nidoqueen and a bunch
of other exciting evolutions and we're
gonna do some gym battles but first let
me show you three eggs 310 k eggs that I
got in the past few days I was very
excited to get that chance because it
didn't have a chance to before and she's
great for defending gyms onyx I wasn't
ecstatic about getting onyx obviously
but if I do have a bunch of candies now
for the second generation so hopefully
I'll be able to get it awesome steelix
and of course when I got another Snorlax
I was ecstatic one of the best book line
the game and now I got two and they're
both my strongest pokemon
I also encountered some very rare
Pokemon including a gang gar and a
Kabutops which was insane and i ended up
catching them both I told by log
continues as i go to Brock to do some
epic evolutions and hopefully find some
more rare pokemon i got to know you
since you don't want to not okay okay
look at that okay so the cool thing in
the car guys is our Tara hatchet to keg
and the record it it was a what was it
Pikachu I'll take it to her first big am
excited what she ran into outside was
this bad boy snorlax 1735 CP and
probably the best moveset you can get
for him any words my aunt said it looked
like a Teletubby you but that so guys
we're gonna go to sink out there today
stake out this downtown but it's super
windy outside so we can't record because
it would be horrible but what we're
going to do instead is we're gonna we've
been saving up some evolutions to show
you guys so we're going to do epic
evolution spri liked all of them in a
row
and you get to see some sick evolutions
and then we're at Brock here so we're
gonna battle some gyms right now we're
just gonna go hit up some polka stops
okay guys so just if you don't believe
how windy it was look at this precious
precious
okay guys so we're gonna do some
evolutions right now and then we're
gonna test them out at Jim's first ones
growlithe CP 732 let's see what its
gonna be some like I said our can I was
next last episode and I was right let's
see he bald yes
this is one of my favorite Pokemon fair
market and are actually cues like in the
full-on world like it's like twice the
size of ash man you focus on edit or
pokédex 1660 as flamethrower has a
pretty good moveset and
right now it's gonna be our fourth
strongest pokemon just stick so i'll
show you guys some cool ones so seal do
gone was definitely one of my fav for
fun I don't know if these guys will be
that strong but let's take a look do you
like do gon care
all right we're going to find out very
sick
what do you think offenses he looks like
a princess yeah he's very cute probably
one of the best looking pokemon and 1192
CP so that great but it's it's moveset
it's pretty slick I'm very excited to
very excited about the little King
little Queen combination and we're gonna
get both today so I'm psyched about that
look at a look at that beef this is one
of the best football in the game so it's
like out let's see what the CP is gonna
pee
1355 not bad and megahorn anyways 784 so
it's better than our in torino so let's
see what the CP for noodle queen is
going to be we have a lot of candy so we
can power her up a lot but I promise era
that I wouldn't use the power-ups until
25 so I don't want to waste startup
least it seems so many I see so many no
please no fighting gems that this is so
happy to have one round oh man I can't
wait to test you smoke one out you know
1395 somos 1400 excellent Oh amazing
will set poison jab and earthquake that
is sick yeah so Tara's got pressing mom
on this one this is Tara name the river
that was her idea a fire pokémon named
River all right you ready names out of
wood are we ready
she's so good
and the CP multiply prasanth I so it's
got to be at least alert
view always one of my favorite Pokemon
nine tails and you too we're like my to
fear of old one so this is a big one to
get 1225 not bad and amber and planes
are as a move set pretty sick
alright guys now we're gonna see there's
been a lot of talk about the weather
drainer thing still works or not so what
me and they're gonna do is we named two
V's Rainer and we're going to evolve in
the side to side for you and yeah and
then we're going to see whether it still
works because i have three that it
worked for so i don't think thing is
true that it only works once so let's
see what happen sighs let's do this
evolve yes
we took notes and second
Oh what do you think I think there's no
work
I think it's going to work
Oh anything but wow so I guess that's
right you can't you can't name um Rainer
anymore I won't work there's like a
hundred one I know as yeah there's a
terrible multiplier for for Joel towns
but no matter it's still pretty cool hey
guys pterodactyl
all munching
raspberry
they're already caught it like a pro so
scared was going to be there oh god oh
god go click it it's not working i had
to logout ba gattaca ever like it wasn't
there terrible level is yours 721 son
Arjun 21 okay raspberry watch a ball
it's gonna be a curve oh god
okay completely under it I don't know
how that happened Oh God gonna waste all
the LG wall
it's worth it oh it's not having it oh
god it wasn't it was like a bit
yes yes hyper-v fight sick sick sick
sick all right amazing there's also
stylist nearby there's a girl nearby but
we already got an argument all right I
don't I need one more so now we're
actually trying to like take this gym
because there's like six or seven or six
six here there are six here so the goal
is to actually get in here and then
hopefully like no one will be able to
take it down once we get in it's taking
a while for us to raise the prestige of
the gym but it shouldn't be too bad
we'll keep at it I don't know how long
she'll keep out alright guys so we got
into that gym I left the Pokemon there
its third out of seven unbelievable and
i just want to show you guys some of
these nature shots because this is
actually a beautiful path and it's at
Brock University where we caught an air
dactyl and where I heard that there's a
dragonite so can't wait to run into that
guy as well so we're just about to level
up this gym so we can leave a Pokemon in
there and the craziest thing is that we
have our two strongest pokemon to snore
LAX's already engines that were strong
and so the best thing I can leave is
actually the lowest Pokemon into gym so
team mystic is doing insane at Brock
Tara's getting tired what an awesome day
another awesome day for Pokemon I mean
we got some amazing new very rare
Pokemon and I'm psyched about my
arcanine and my nine tails especially
but we got a bunch of other new
evolutions that were amazing and we
found an Aerodactyl and caught it that
was I was probably the highlight of the
day insane in the same gameplay and yeah
I can't wait we still want to receive
all of our ride horn into a ride on I
can't wait for that I can't wait for the
slowpokes become a skull bro and you
know we're already like halfway to level
25 so it's like a more exciting from
here give it a thumbs up guys if you
liked it and i'll see you next time